what is your advice to a young person
who wants to pursue screenwriting I mean
right right right as much as you can
which is really difficult writing is
hard and I would say to the subject of
writing don't judge your drafts right
away don't tell yourself oh it's dumb I
don't like it and throw it away really
get it in in front of people have
readings is a really easy way to just
hear it out loud and kind of get it
outside of your own head and you know
the prospect of making a movie can be
daunting but getting friends together
who are actors or even other just people
that you know and you like to just hear
it out loud is is cheap and it's it's
accessible and it forces you to listen
to your work with with new ears I would
say make your own because I think
screenwriting is so much you know it's
always a blueprint for the movie and I
think directing what you've written is
is a good litmus test to see if it's if
it's working